For some reason, we can't see you.
Talked into a little bit of a... Yeah, I'm on my phone right now. I'm going to see if I can get a little to my computer here.
Oh, okay. Are you outside?
No, I um...
I'm having problems with my computer.
It sounds, everyone sounds like chipmunks on my headset, on my computer. It's really weird. It's like the Hertz rate or whatever is wrong. And everyone I talk to sounds like a chipmunk. It's pretty funny at first, but then you can't understand them.
Ohh.
So, I've been taking calls on my phone.
People would have thought that it was.
Okay.
So how have you been?
And.
I'm doing okay. I think I just walked into a quagmire this morning, but I'm still learning.
Justin, I think I lost you in between. I could not hear you properly.
And you are muted if you are speaking.
Listen, you there?
Yeah.
Looks like he's trying to transition to the.
Maybe, yeah, transfer it to the laptop.
All right.
Can you hear me?
Yes, we can hear you now.
Yes, we can.
Awesome. OK, and.
Can you see me? Aha! Here we go.
Ohh, there you go.
Much better, much better.
Video on my computer, audio on my phone, everything's working alright, so...
Who?
Great.
Good.
So, how are things going?
They're going alright.
Yeah, like I said, there's some technical issues this morning, but I don't have the full story yet. So tell me my next thing we do.
Singh.
Yeah, yeah, everything's good. Been really busy. We had a big go live recently. And that's been taking a lot of our time. The customer had two front two ERP systems going at once. And four days before go live, they canceled one of them.
I.
because they weren't talking to each other like they promised. And so that was messy. But...
But.
They're up and running. Everything's good there. It's taking a lot of time.
Great, and how's the people doing?
Doing good? Doing good. I hear you're sick. Sorry to hear that.
But yeah, as soon as he can get back to work, we do miss him.
Yep, as you know, Vibhu was not feeling well yesterday and today, so he had to be on off, so, but he will log in from tomorrow.
Mhm.
Yeah, he mentioned in the chat.
Yep.
I think I just figured out what he meant. Okay, never mind.
It's a term we don't use here, and uh, and uh...
And I didn't understand what it meant, and now I do.
It's a police motion.
OK, by the way, Justin, did you receive, did you receive the feedback C-SAT survey for Vivu?
Ohh, let me find it.
Now, we just changed mail filtering programs, so I'd not be surprised if that that was another.
Mm.
Interesting thing. We last minute changed mail filtering programs for all our clients, and that that hasn't been a great project by any means. I don't know, some sort of contract thing that we had to get out of it sooner than expected.
You have not. Okay.
That one wasn't on me though, it wasn't my project. So let me see if I can find it.
That.
It was sent last week. Let me go ahead and read it.
Okay, that'd be great.
In the meantime, you can tell us how, how is uh, doing? How is he performing?
You doing good? You doing good?
Yeah, I've been given a space to work on that DSI printer stuff that's...
Dates coming up soon.
Basically, it's one of those things as a moving date back because the client is changing their mind. But the goals haven't done in the next two weeks. And so that's been the primary thing. And then he's helped with adding us to the
for getting us to use the new SharePoint migration tool, which has been very useful. And so that's been good.
In fact, it really helped with that DSI client, so...
That's been good. Yeah.
That's great.
Thank you so much for sharing it. I have also retriggered the CSAT Service, so it should be there in your mailbox in a minute or two.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, before I jump into the presentation deck, anything else, Justin, you want to share?
I don't think so.
I didn't say anything. I'm sorry I'm not all here today. You know, like I said, we've been in chaos last week or so, having that last week. So I'm a little bit...
OK.
Out there right now, but.
Look completely understandable.
Just a moment, I'm sharing my screen.
Okay.
All right, here we go.
Let me know, Justin, if you're able to see it.
All right.
Yep, yep, I see it.
It's.
Just a moment, I think I've shared the wrong screen. Just a moment.
Mhm.
Yep, I got the email and the Partner feedback.
Yeah, you can be a sticker of that until I reshare.
Right.
Is it that?
Yep, no, it's perfect.
Yep, yep, we're good.
Thank you. So welcome to our monthly business review and the review duration is May 4th till May 29th. Starting with our agenda items for today, which remains the same. We have check-in, highlights of the account, action tracker, performance analysis, voice of customer, way forward, and then recap.
No.
We have already covered how things at this moment, so I can skip this slide.
Mmh.
The discussion points we had in our previous connect where we had received good feedback about Vibhu's progress. He's doing good technically, able to work on projects independently, so that's good. We also worked and discussed about Vibhu working on.
Mhm, mhm.
projects where he can, you know, single-handedly manage a project and take ownership to get him the insight about various phases of a project. This is where we are working on internally.
At the same time, we also discussed the KPIs, finalized the KPIs, and I will go through it as the slide progresses. So yeah, any questions so far?
Mhm.
That's it.
No questions.
Thank you.
Okay, with action tracker, so reports to be scheduled for tracking utilization. So this is something that we are still waiting on. And the KPIs for Bibu, they have been completed.
Next is the discussed KPIs that we had. So, excuse me, as per the previous month's performance, people had been on track with all the matrices that we finalized. Just want to know from your side, Justin, do you feel that if he's
off track on any of these parameters or is he on track.
I think it's on track.
Okay, I will fill in the details for the month of May before I share this deck with you.
Kip.
Moving on to performance analysis, this is where we have the utilization trend for people.
Mm-hmm.
The 5th of May was an off due to Memorial Day.
Mhm.
Um, yeah, this is what we have, uh, that is utilization piece. Any questions there?
No, no.
Okay, next is the tickets worked.
So, although people worked on project tickets only, they spent throughout the week, but he could not close any because the project extended had been extended during the for the entire month, which is why the closure is less as completed.
The.
that he worked on, but at the same time, the time that he entered into those tickets had been the available site, which means whatever work he did was the available work.
Kip.
Yeah.
Let me know if you have any questions or anything that you want to share.
No, no, no, that's understandable.
Okay.
Thank you.
OK, way forward. This is where we will continue to upkill himself. KPIs something that we have already completed, continuity. Vibhu is already working to make sure that he is preparing to scale delivery and board reviews which I conduct.
so that we are on the same page in terms of the expectations and deliverables.
Mhm, mhm.
Yes.
This is I think GPS slide. I'll skip this one and that is it.
Awesome.
Thank you.
It looks like as you forget to add the build it live details. Let me take care of it. So Justin, I believe I have already shared the code and the link for the registration. So would you or Chad, will you guys be able to make it this time?
Any other question?
Mhm.
I, I don't, I don't think I can; I have.
Pretty busy summer, but you know, I was a teacher. She's off in the summer, so we have some days planned this summer for things, and I did pass it along to Chad.
No.
Only me or you're breaking up.
Ohh.
Sorry, you were breaking up.
Okay, yeah, yeah, yeah. So I won't be able to attend. I did pass the information on to Chad and we haven't discussed it.
Yeah.
Keith.
So I don't think so, but he didn't. He didn't mention it when we had our meeting yesterday, so I don't think he plans to.
OK, no worries.
Thank you. No, thank you. Thank you for sharing the details. Rest, I'll try to reach out to chat separately and see to it in case if there is something which we can help him out to get him to the invite. We would love to have you all here.
Mm.
Yeah, I do think it'd be a good, good thing for him.
Yeah, I do think it'd be a good thing for him. He's he's putting Claude Cowork on his computer now and starting to work with that, so so he's he's planning on that.
For sure, for sure.
Ohh.
Nice, we have got the Fable version launched as well.
Okay.
Nice. I have been myself, like me myself personally, I have been a great fan of Cloud now, like since the day I started using it. It's making life so much easier. So no doubt about that. And true, true. Really amazing tool.
Yeah.
Yeah, it's a powerful program.
But yeah, he would benefit from having some, how he can take the technology further into the business. That would be good, you know, especially on the billing and they spend so much time. We have a staff position that does spreadsheets and I don't even think that's needed anymore. You know, obviously someone has to take the time to train the
So.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Um...
Mhm.
No, true.
AI first, but that might be something that can go away. I don't know.
Not even the training, rather the amazing part is like when you start working on it, it feels so impressive. Like the kind of work which you can complete within such a short span of time. That's really impressive. So something in case if you and the rest of the team, if you are also focusing more on the AI implementation part.
Yeah.
Mhm.
So we do have our quarterly AI MSP mastermind, our peer group, dedicated peer group, where we can customize the bots like you were talking about the revenue dashboard, the leakage which is happening. We have created custom bots who can go ahead and take care of the dispatching. Even these bots have.
Mmhm.
Kip.
been trained so that they can go ahead and take care of the L1 task. So let me know whenever you have a word with Chad or if you guys, both of you would like to go for an AI or the used cases or probably a demo. I can definitely book that one for you which can make better.
the things way more easier the way we are growing.
Mhm.
Kip.
Yes, I'll keep that in mind. Thank you.
Awesome. Thank you so much. Over to you, Ashish.
Great.
Yeah, thank you so much, Sarbjeet. Really appreciate Justin for sharing feedback about people and the point that we have discussed, who is doing a good job. He will resume work from tomorrow. And you have received the CSAT server, right, for the month of May?
Yep, yep, yep, I have it up now. I'll submit it in a minute.
Okay, great.
Great. So yeah, I'm looking forward to get the feedback there. Yep.
And Ashish, so sorry to interrupt, but just on the similar line, if we can also send the NPS survey for Q1.
to Justin, I'll help you out. Just give me one minute, Justin. I'll go ahead and send it out right away to you while you are there on the call. Or would you like me to send it in the email, whatever that's preferred? Here you go. I have a 20.
I don't have access to the NPS.
Okay, I'll look for that.
Okay.
Well, anyway, where is more convenient?
Can put it in China filter.
Right away, here you go.
It's there in the chat, Justin. So that's for the overall services from Ashmi, Vibhu, from IT by Design as a whole. How would you like to rate us on a scale of 1 to 10, 9, 10 being promoters? And if you would like us to refer to any one of your friends. So we'd love to see your comments there.
OK.
Mm.
Okay, opening up. Awesome.
Singh.
Great. Thank you so much for your time, Justin. Rest you have a great week ahead and we'll be in touch. Take care. Bye bye.
Yep, we have open. Thank you.
All right. Thank you. Have a great day.
Thank you so much.
Thank you, Kip.
Ohh, that's my tune. I recently got it.
SharePoint.
What is this?
Yes.
Team.
I...